it's been called the worst natural
disaster in Libya's modern history in
September Heavy Rain from Storm Daniel
devastated much of Eastern Libya
official numbers say
4,333 people died and more than
8,500 remain missing in the city of DNA
two dams collapsed sending a tsunami
like wave through the city entire
neighborhoods were Swept Away into the
sea or reduced to Rubble salam's home
was destroyed private Charities are now
paying for him and his family to live in
misrata he says it was a nightmare as
water flooded his home he scrambled to
save his
children I climbed up with two of my
children when I got to the roof of my
house I found a woman there I thought it
was my mother but it was a woman who
lives far away the flood wased her into
my roof which is three stories high so
imagine how high the water was it was a
catastrophe it's a day we can never
forget but Alm was unable to save his
parents he buried them the next day
according to the un's migration agency
more than
43,000 people were displaced by the
floods in eastern Libya the majority are
from the city of DNA Ali na works in the
ministry of social Affairs he says more
than 270 families displaced from DNA
have relocated to misrata but they get
little government
support until now the government has not
allocated any funds to those who have
been displaced or the municipalities
that receive them everything that is
offered to them in misrata is from the
people of the city to help their fellow
countrymen Libya has two rival
governments that's complicated relief
efforts each says it's allocated a
budget to help those displaced and to
rebuild areas wrecked by the floods but
on the ground so far those funds
don't make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz